so let's let's draw this conversation
out of the schools and into what
manifests in the real world
we we mentioned this earlier on this uh
gwen berry olympic athlete
goes viral because she's third place
hammer thrower
for the u.s olympic trials to join the
team she gets approved
and when the anthem plays she looks all
angry at the camera and you know
doesn't salute or doesn't put her hand
in her heart and then she puts a shirt
on her head saying activist athlete
just a few years prior she was holding
up the american flag with a smile on her
face
we can see how this starts to manifest
in the real world we have a couple of
these stories
first squad member blasts july 4th
celebrations
black people still aren't free this
generated some controversy
uh corey bush a democrat dismissed
independence day sunday as a holiday
meant for white people before claiming
the land is stolen land and black people
still aren't free we also have maxine
waters
who is not a a new member of congressman
for a long time
drags the declaration of independence on
july 4th
maxine waters would she have maybe she
would have
but i kind of feel like she wouldn't
have gone this far to criticize
independence day
were it not for the the change in
culture and the feeling this is what you
need to say
to be accepted to be approved of zooby
the rapper
has a thread and in it he's like here's
some things i've learned over the past
you know years so
one of them is that people would rather
be socially accepted than be right
people would would rather sacrifice
their principles if it means they will
be socially accepted things like that
yeah he's correct well it's tribal right
and so it's that
concept that i had to struggle with
within the muslim community when you
dare to challenge the orthodoxy you get
thrown out of the tribe
and we ended up for example in our
community fighting for women's rights
my mom didn't get invitations anymore to
the potluck dinners
and she said i don't want to go to their
potluck dinners and so that's the
sacrifice that you have to make
when yeah this is very important it was
inspiring to me yeah
this is very much a cultural revolution
yeah and so this next door i want to
highlight just a few of these
national geographic tweets that july 4th
fireworks are racist
smoke targets communities of color then
we have the story npr
uh decry's declaration of independence
as documents with flaws and deeply
ingrained hypocrisies
what are they working for the crown now
they want us to return to the british
empire
one of the arguments made by many on the
left is that if we never had
independence
then the slavery abolishment act of
parliament in 1833 would have affected
the american colonies and ended slavery
some 30 years sooner
maybe or i argue that if the cop if the
southern colonies
are the southern states were still
colonies of great britain they would
have actually pushed back
and it would have caused the same level
of conflict and strife
and potentially even resulted in a war
for independence
or at the very least it could have put
pressure on the crown
to wait because they were like well we
have these colonies that produce for us
we need to understand is that it may
actually have been the american
revolution
which helped the uk and slavery in that
if the crown was still
taxing southern states and the states
relied on slaves to produce the crown
may have been like well
you know we're making a lot of money
over here we can't just do it
right but who knows we don't know for
sure what i can say is when they come
out with these nonsensical statements
like
fireworks are racist right what that
what's happening is
they introduce juneteenth then they
disparage july 4th
i think charlie kirk mentioned it was
evanston illinois yeah that got rid of
their july 4th celebration
but had a pride and juneteenth
celebration yeah and so it's
the it's this indoctrination of ideas
spilling now into popular culture right
like what is it that you can wear what
is it you can't wear
how is it that you signal you know your
amazing political correctness
and so this is the politics spilling
into
everyday life and um i walked by the
uh grocery store the cereal aisle
and had the you know new cereal that's
got all the multiple yeah right
right yeah that's so weird the pride
cereal yeah the pride cereal
i mean so it's commercialization that's
now
chasing this new ideology and um
and we have to just use our critical
thinking yeah
yeah catalogs has a a lgbtq pride
together cereal
right i'm not sure what it is is it just
fruit loops i don't know isn't it seem
like it
i know that's exactly what it looks like
loops that's kind of insulting
what the heck yeah i'm pretty sure it's
just fruit loops it looks like it but
it's got all the characters together
and it's really fascinating when you see
all these corporations changing their
logos there's a really funny meme
where it's a bunch of uh evil
corporations from video games and movies
uh with rainbow logos like umbrella core
yeah they make the zombies
right and they the umbrella's got a
rainbow on right there's aperture
laboratories which is the the
experimenting on humans and that's a
rainbow
yeah we get the massive multinational
corporations are on our side apparently
yeah i mean this is the term that they
call woke capital right
the whole idea of the
industry corporate america that's what i
spent 15 years reporting at the wall
street journal
i love covering marketing because
marketing was basically propaganda isn't
it interesting yeah
and propaganda is all this i mean you
make it
fancy you make it colorful you make it
read you know you you confuse people
you end up and you end up selling your
idea
we want to be optimistic that these
conversations and the parents standing
up will
succeed but i worry that it's
it's the average person doesn't care at
all now the point bannon was making was
that these moms are the average person
who are standing up being like
what is this so perhaps i think the
important thing is not necessarily to be
optimistic or pessimistic
maybe just to be vigilant right
right and and pay attention yes and stay
focused and don't back down
yeah there's um my favorite idea
our president nikki neely said it on an
interview a while ago that the price of
freedom is vigilant internal vigilance
yeah yes and i'll tell you it really hit
home this
um this fourth of july weekend i went to
visit my parents in morgantown west
virginia went
took my uno cards because i was gonna
play uno with my dad
well in the ptsa at
the school from where my son just
graduated thomas jefferson high school
for science and technology we had
four parents seize the majority
of the ptsa seats and those four parents
are against critical race theory
therefore
merit and guess what the president-elect
is the first black president-elect
chosen for the ptsa and he's against
critical race theory
because he wants merit he doesn't want
this like bigotry of low expectations
who wants their kids to be told they can
never succeed yeah so this weekend
the minority party so to speak the
people who want to push critical race
theory
and race based admissions
they staged a coup and they tried to
basically
unseat these parents who are
trying to change the policy so that we
can fight critical race theory in the
school
i i guess what we won we won we defeated
a coup
and i do vigilance i do want to add a
little bit of a good news into the mix
because we can talk all negative and get
all down and people are like oh man but
we got the story from fox
walmart shoppers break out into star
spangled banner over 4th of july weekend
in viral video
yeah the video is actually quite
incredible it's just people shopping
right
when all of a sudden everyone's standing
right in the aisles and they're singing
the national anthem
yeah and that's in our hearts you know
that is so in our hearts and
we were as parents this weekend i didn't
get to play my uno
harry didn't get to grill on time with
his family he was trying
but we were doing this because we love
this country and
yuyan she stood in tiananmen square
to fight the oppression there and this
weekend what did she do
she created beautiful graphics with
flags of america
talking about defending democracy you
know that's
that's the fight that's the vigilance
that's the vigilance that we're talking
about
and and if every parent does it in
whatever
corner of the school system that they're
in
wherever you are in corporate america
wherever you are
in uh in your neighborhood you know uh
hoa that wants to now rule what sign you
can put and you can't put the blue line
you know
flag up and all of this stuff like you
have to be vigilant and protect rights
i watched a little historical video
about the star-spangled banner
and what the song actually means and i
think a lot of people probably don't
know this because i certainly didn't
that what does it mean with the rockets
red glare the bombs bursting in air
gave proof through the night the flag
was still there it was that as the bombs
were exploding the flashes of light
you could then see the flag just very
briefly and every time they would
shell this this this town or this this
the city or the fort
they would they would still see the flag
standing it couldn't be knocked down and
actually actually as the story goes it
could be legend but
they say the shells were actually
killing people and the flag was knocked
down several times
finally after the battle was over when
they went back to the fort and saw the
flag's still standing it was being held
up by the corpses of the men who refused
to back down
that every time the flag would go down
they would lift it back up
as they were getting shelled and then
die on the flag wow that's what it meant
it meant that there was an oppressive
authority that did not
not respect the will of the people and
the people of this country
said we we will not abide by this we
will fight for our freedoms
and now you have people who are using
these morsels of truth
manipulations lies and constant
negativity to try and take those
freedoms away
arguing what that uh uh it's bad
that we had independence because the
crown abolished slavery first
okay be like the uk i guess with no
guaranteed rights
yeah you know they want to get rid of
all these mascots and these names of
people that they
decided are on the incorrect side of
history but
ultimately we needed all of those folks
to get to where we're at today
and maybe the journey wasn't perfect of
course it wasn't perfect and there were
injustices against all people but you
don't
the fundamental reason why i oppose
critical race theory is because
it rightly says that there was a
hierarchy of human value
but it incorrectly now wants to bring a
new hierarchy of human value to people
and that's just fundamentally immoral
unethical
and unacceptable and that's what we have
to fight
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members
only content segments you can't get
anywhere else go to timcast.com become a
member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you